tomorrow's gonna be nuts and there's a
lot of really weird things going on so i
think we should just uh
jump right in my question to you guys
whoever wants to go is uh
who's gonna win well so here's
here's how tomorrow's gonna play out
right um you're
the left has already kind of said this
and the media is sort of massaging this
talking point into their
broadcasting where they're talking about
this thing called a red mirage
and a red mirage is what they claim
it means that donald trump is going to
look like he has this
massive electoral victory tomorrow nate
silver even talked about this
um and yet then the mail-in ballots in
some of these states
will get counted later and then so that
is going to be cut into
now in some states they do it
differently in some states they'll begin
counting
immediately when the polls open in other
states they're waiting until after they
have
social listening concerns or there just
literally don't have the personnel to be
able to do this
and so my prediction is chaos
lots of chaos because all right
you might end up having a situation
where
it looks like trump ran the table um
wins all the swing states and then some
of those states
that look red might start flipping blue
and no one's going to trust that
and where's where's the level of trust
in our national institutions
to show somebody something like that
right now right i mean i am
so hesitant usually to make predictions
especially when perhaps if i say so they
get 24 hours we're all gonna look so
stupid but
my gut instincts and it's kind of like
one of those examples of don't believe
your lying eyes right when i see the
huge
enormous rallies in places like
pennsylvania
and you know even in places like arizona
was it 96 miles the
little trump caravan they had wow i feel
like trump has a
legitimate chance of winning but the
whole thing with the mail-in ballots all
of that
happening i'm not sure i think you know
what's probably gonna happen
is that in a lot of these swing states
it's gonna lean toward trump and then
people are gonna say hang on we can't
yet call it because we have all these
extra ballots to count
and i've seen some people say that might
even take up two weeks
and i think like you said tim a lot of
people aren't going to trust that and i
think there's not enough confidence
that you know mainland voting is secure
that people are going to accept that and
i
i'm nervous i'm hoping that the
election results either way are so
strong where they they can't really be
contested but i think
i don't think that's gonna be the case
the only way trump wins tomorrow night
and the left says okay okay trump won is
if he gets like
okay so if there are 20 million people
in pennsylvania
and we get 15 million votes trump with 8
million biden with 7
they're going to say there's 5 million
more votes that could potentially come
in the mail
that's enough for biden to win so it
would have to be
trump would have to have a lead above
biden more than the remaining population
of
people who are not counted as voting
yeah it actually used to be in
pennsylvania is my home state i worked a
lot of elections there statewide um but
it doesn't matter the election law is
the same regardless of size election
so it used to be that on election day if
you're and this probably won't be true
for tomorrow but it used to be
this idea that because those are all
unofficial right those are always
unofficial and then the officials come
in later
right but it used to be that in the
unofficial tally you wouldn't even dip
into the absentee ballots
if your delta was less than your margin
of victory so if the amount of absentee
ballots you have come in that was
less then let's say that was you know
five points but you had a ten point lead
well then it wouldn't matter because you
wouldn't be able to swing the election
so
you would get to them of course you'd
make sure they're they're counted but
you wouldn't need to get to them on
election night because it wouldn't make
it
you can still call it is the weird thing
i remember seeing
in the midterms there were some
districts where it was like 30 percent
reporting but that's enough for us to
say this democrat had won
because there's no way with the rest of
the precincts reporting it would be
enough people to
outweigh like the urban center so that's
not by population it was by like the
amount of precincts
but they're saying everything is
opposite now nothing makes sense
we're just supposed to sit back and wait
until all the ballots are counted
but we don't know what all the ballots
means the mayor of philadelphia jim
kenney said this came
out and said this morning definitively
that it will take us several days to
count the ballots and he said we have we
have 400 000 mail-in ballots and it will
take us several days
okay well as long as they know what the
number is but i guess the the real issue
is
i mean we are going to see okay you know
what i'm going to say i'm totally
getting banned from youtube
in the next several days or something
because you're not allowed to to
question this stuff i'm not kidding
i did a video on project veritas i don't
know if you guys saw that expose they
did where they caught that lady bragging
about
you know give me money and i'll get you
votes right right they demonetized it i
didn't get a strike or anything
and they did monetize it a few days
later and they told me that what i
said could scare people into not voting
and i was like i covered a news story
about one lady who was caught engaging
in fraud and they're like
yeah but just so you know
it's like okay okay we know here's
what's gonna happen first they've
already started banning tons of people
you know uh i don't know if you guys
have seen these stories trump tweeted
about it facebook groups
and yeah people are just getting
eliminated i'm willing to bet
tomorrow trump's gonna have a a very
very clear
definitive majority this is my this is
my prediction which i know
in a day they're going to be like you're
so dumb damn wow okay so i think trump's
going to do really really well in the
key states he needs to win
it's going to look like historic voter
turnout it's going to be epic
and then they're going to say we refuse
to call it we're going to wait
until all the votes come in but they're
not going to know
if even if they say like we sent out 400
000 is that that was philadelphia
that's what kenny said yeah what they
sent out are they received
i would have to double check but i know
the number he said that's 400 000 right
because that's a huge difference and i
think that's probably what you're
getting right if
i think i think it was received okay if
they send out
like look at new jersey how many how
many mail-in ballots did jersey send out
how many people live in jersey 8 million
or something right
everybody got a ballot plus people don't
live there that's the craziest thing
i i'm not college kids that aren't in
school what do you do with that
that are that are that are like not not
from jersey but that are not
not from jersey but what have they
registered at their dorm did they
register at the apartment
now they're back with their parents then
then what do you do with that
i'm willing to bet you're gonna you're
gonna see that new jersey issued more
melon ballots and they have people in
the state
not surprising well cause i can i can
tell you because uh
in the primary i got a bout to my house
for someone who didn't live there and
didn't request one
it was a primary ballot and now a ballot
got sent to my house
with one name on the envelope and differ
a different name
inside the envelope and so it's not my
business not my ballot so i'm gonna
leave it to the people who got the belt
and they can they can deal with it
but uh what basically what i'm saying is
i've seen
the failure but you've also got all
these uh posts popping up people saying
you know i got bounced to my house
people
from people who are dead so that means
if i saw this from a lot in california
that means more ballots than people are
being sent out
right so this is uh this is where that
sort of
and the democrats know this right
they're very they're very well aware of
this and they know they put all their
chips in
on mail-in ballots even though in a lot
of these swing states pennsylvania
specifically because i know that went
very well
they're worried about this and so why
they're doing this is because they're
they're putting out that phrase and
you're hearing this phrase again and
again we need to count all the ballots
count all the ballots but you notice
they never
add we need to verify the ballots we
need to check the ballots the ballots
need to have integrity
well in their minds that's voter
surprise what does all the ballots mean
josh shapiro a.g of pennsylvania what do
you mean all the ballots
and he said when we count all the
ballots trump will will have lost when
he he said on october 31st on halloween
evening he said
and this is a guy i've known 15 years
back when he was state rep josh shapiro
and he usually doesn't go full mask off
like that you always have to kind of
like read between the lines on him
he said when we count all the bout
all the ballots trump will have lost how
can an election official
say something like that in a state like
pennsylvania
which is such a vital state probably it
is the vital state i've been saying
again and again pennsylvania is the
keystone
and yet you have an official saying that
and here's the thing democrats control
pretty much everything in the state of
pennsylvania right now just is what it
is they control the supreme court they
control gerrymandering and redistricting
they control the governor they control
the attorney general they obviously
control
uh the city of philadelphia sometimes i
think it's like moscow on the delaware
over there um which and believe me i
work in elections philadelphia a long
time
um yeah i was the temple republican
temple university
republican chairman for you know i was
there for four years north philly so
believe me i've seen
i've seen i was there when the black
panthers came out in 2008 in front of
the polls you know that was back
we didn't have iphones back then that
was all flip videos that we gave
everybody to like hey see something film
something and that's where it started
and look at where that's going too so
um i don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow in the city but we're going to
be on hand to find out right
well what's kind of concerning about it
is that people like us who kind of
question hey there's potential for fraud
right this is not a secure system
now the democrats have kind of set this
narrative up where if there's anything
that's called into question after the
fact
they're gonna brand you know conspiracy
theorists uh you're trying to
subvert democracy and things like that
and i actually think
and you guys can disagree but i don't
think you will that
big tech if anyone starts to say
something like i don't know if this is
legit or valid that's probably going to
be bad
uh grounds for being wrong wrong
snap rug if joe biden says it it'll be
oh that's true
yeah yeah yeah so no you're right you're
right but yeah if the democrats do it
they're going to be like well
right joe biden is allowed to declare
victory trump is not i'll never forget
the words mark zuckerberg used in that
you know it's one of the like one of
those memes like
no one absolutely no one mark zuckerberg
explaining how the elections will be
verified like
wait nobody asked you about this mark
zuckerberg why are you
why are you cutting a video on this you
said we said we're gonna wait for there
to be a
consensus result before we
allow someone to declare victory on our
platform they may not
no it's it's just a consensus mark joe
biden's the the constitution
the states who what do you mean you're a
silicon valley billionaire
yeah and i think you have no role here
one of the biggest failures of the
republican administration over the past
four years in my opinion
has not been being harsh enough
on big tech and i i know there's a lot
of libertarians who think
it's a private company they can do
whatever they want and it's like all i
want
is for big tech to live up to the same
standards of operations that so many
in other industries have to live by and
you know obviously you've talked a lot
about things like section 230
i'm not in favor of repealing section
230 entirely i just don't think that
facebook should be able to claim that
they're just a platform when they're
actually making these editorial
decisions
they've been more and more blatant i
mean section 230 was written before
these companies existed
yeah and not like this world that we
inhabit right now didn't exist when
it was 1996 yeah we didn't exist back
then
we need to change it i mean it's obvious
and we definitely i mean the executive
order that trump put out regarding
section 230 i think was solid and if you
actually read it
based on what he put out the outlines
there is no way that places like
facebook twitter or youtube can claim
protection under section 230 so
you know unlike what a lot of people
think i don't want the us government
to nationalize facebook and twitter i
would love to see like you know
the fcc or something actually come out
and say based on this
we we are ruling that these protections
no longer apply to facebook twitter etc
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you